[Musique]
parce que j'ai besoin que tu signé un
papier pour luc je te les envoyer plus
toujours du mannequinat luc adore ça le
mannequinat c'est sa passion le
mannequinat c'est sa passion qui fait
pas partie de sa vie ça change rien pour
toi alors tu fais pas chier le monde
présent tout séjour je viens rendre
visite à de la famille vous avez été
signalé je suis pas dangereux du tout je
suis humoriste je suis personnel
et tout ça c'est en france oui quoi j'en
sais rien c'est juste que c'est pas ici
c'est ça oui joue acte a été l'assistant
de david spade
en fait j'ai été le stagiaire de
l'assistant de david spade c'est pour ça
que j'ai mis une astérisque où il ya
écrit stagiaires ouais mais adore y en a
partout la 2d * est donc ouais segal qui
sérieux est venu jusqu'ici je veux
accomplir mon devoir de père je suis un
des mannequins et vous êtes monsieur
lennon non mais je suis son père
biologique
l'homme que je considère comme mon vrai
père ne pourra pas venir
jason alan gross était pas connue en
france ou un truc du genre ouais mais on
s'en fout bas rêve à ce qu elle sait pas
aux états unis c'est clair c'est fini je
laisse tomber l'humour
j'arrête définitivement tant mieux parce
que je déteste l'humour l'humour c'est
pas trop le style de la maison
quand on voit l'état du monde en ce
moment il n'y a vraiment pas de quoi se
marrer ou
je peux pas laisser jason alan gross à
élever mon fils jason c'est un demi dieu
pour lui il est bronzé le torse épilé où
je peux rivaliser tu vas y arriver
devant arriver à luc tu veux mais d où
elle retourne à paris
la bataille star n'est jamais trop tard
vous le dites aussi trop peu et trop
tard tu la connais celle là
cette panne guerre si c'est lui
lui c'est gad il est connu il a pas
l'air cool quoi
ouais il est français mais ça va aller
[Musique]